close your eyes and think of the worst
movie you saw in 2021 got it good now
forget it because we can pretty much
guarantee that these were a whole lot
worse
from the exorcist to the devils to the
omen the 1970s were undoubtedly a golden
age for religious horror movies there
have been a few standout additions to
the subgenre since but most contemporary
faith-based horrors failed to capture
the haunting magic of the apomentic
classics and 2021 zion holy is a prime
example it's the story of a
hearing-impaired girl named alice who
after a visit from the virgin mary finds
that she has gained the ability to heal
the sick what could possibly go wrong
i slit their windpipes and watch the
breath slowly leak out
as it turns out a lot to put a long
story short the unholy is a tale of
witchcraft deception creepy dolls and uh
journalism disgraced reporter gary fenn
accidentally released the spirit of a
witch who then possessed alice under the
guise of the virgin mary naturally it's
up to him to save her from the clutches
of the aforementioned grumpy crone
cricket brown and jeffrey dean morgan do
their utmost to elevate the cliche
written script but the by the numbers
plot predictable jump scares and
substandard special effects make the
unholy a genuinely unenjoyable
experience perhaps unsurprisingly the
majority of critics had nothing but bad
things to say about this unholy misfire
based on the real-life crimes of the
truck stop killer midnight in the
switchgrass follows two fbi agents carl
helter and his partner rebecca lombardi
who are hunting a serial killer at work
in florida's underworld when lombardi is
kidnapped by the man thereafter helter
teams up with a state level cop to get
her back and catch the killer despite
featuring prominently in the promotional
material bruce willis appears in
precious few scenes in this movie as is
pretty much the norm of these films
nowadays modern willis movies also tend
to get a real hammering from the critics
and midnight in the switch grass is no
exception as the new york times review
said the atmosphere is thoroughly sleazy
without being distinctive and everything
about the movie the emotionless line
readings the half-baked backstories
exudes a terse functionality when the
dust had settled this thoroughly lazy
thriller was left with a damning score
of just eight percent from critics on
rotten tomatoes the only people who
might gain something from midnight in
the switchgrass are fans of megan fox
and machine gun kelly their relationship
began on the set of the movie but even
they're under no illusions about its
quality the couple pulled out of the
premiere and kelly appeared to call the
film trash in a tweet days later by all
rights naked singularity should have
been one of the best movies of 2021
produced by ridley scott and featuring
the likes of olivia cook and john boyega
this unconventional comedy drama had all
the makings of a modern classic while
yega stars is a new york city public
defender going through a moral crisis
after learning that a client is involved
in a 50 million dollar drug deal he
decides to steal the money from right
under their nose there are plenty of
good ideas here but sloppy execution
lets naked singularity down threads that
were fully fleshed out and sergio de la
pava's original novel go nowhere here
and writer director chase palmer doesn't
seem to know what genre his adaptation
belongs to as the new york times puts it
naked singularity welds legal drama and
science fiction into a misshapen crime
caper
when a film has a zero percent rating on
rotten tomatoes a month on from its
release it's usually safe to say that
it's not going to be remembered as a
classic inhabit the debut feature from
writer director janelle shurtcliff
probably won't be remembered by anyone
but die hard fans of bella thorne the
former disney channel actor stars as a
los angeles socialite who pays the bills
by selling drugs for a washed up
hollywood star when a drug deal goes
sour and some cash is stolen she and her
hard partying pals go on the run dressed
as nuns for some reason it really does
seem like shirt cliff woke up one day
and decided that a bunch of la girls
beating the hell out of a guy while
dressed as nuns would look cool on
camera and then proceeded to build an
entire movie around that idea there was
some backlash to the film when it was
announced mostly to do with the casting
of paris jackson as jesus but the final
product is more of a crime against
cinema than anything else abbott tries
so very hard to be edgy so much so that
the movie's press release actually
described it as being reminiscent of
early tarantino the truth is
you're the weak
and i am the tyranny of evil men
but the plot is paper thin and there's
next to nothing in terms of character
development variety definitely summed up
this mercifully short film of the single
sentence in its review calling it a
candy colored dress-up excuse for a
bunch of slumming models rock musicians
and miscellaneous scenesters
where did it all go wrong for neil
blumkamp at one stage the south african
director was in line to take charge of a
new alien movie but his stock has fallen
significantly in recent years in an
interview with the guardian blumkant
recently joked it's possible that ridley
scott watched chappie and he was like
this guy can't do aliens so let's just
go ahead and move on he was speaking to
the british newspaper to promote his
2021 supernatural horror flick demonic
which unfortunately for blumkamp got
panned even worse than his much derided
2015 sci-fi flick champion demonic are
beset by similar issues they're just a
lot more apparent in the latter filmed
during the covet 19 pandemic demonic is
a far more contained movie and therefore
can't always hide behind its vfx it
follows a young woman who gets the
chance to go inside the mind of her
comatose serial killer mother via new
technology when she enters the
simulation however she finds a demon and
it turns out that her mother was
possessed and that the whole experiment
is being overseen by a vatican black ops
unit if this all sounds a little out
there that's because it is what's worse
is that the director seems unwilling to
fully commit to the bonkers premise as
brian talarico of roger ebert.com put it
demonic feels like a film made by
someone who's scared of his own ideas
and his own limitations
people who saw romeo must die back in
2000 probably thought they'd never see
the day that an even worse contemporary
retelling of romeo and juliet could hit
cineplexes but on july 16 2021 that's
exactly what happened die in a gunfight
stars diego banetta and alexandra
daddario as romeo and juliet or actually
ben and mary two star-crossed lovers
from powerful families that have been at
war since the 1860s their families are
determined to keep them apart but as
you've almost certainly figured out by
now they disregard the long-running feud
and follow their hearts instead viking
star travis fimmel also shows up as a
typically intense hitman and the film is
narrated by billy crudup for some reason
upon seeing it it becomes clear why this
movie spent over a decade in development
hell zac efron was all set to star in
and produce diana gunfight in 2010
variety later claimed that josh
hutcherson and kya scodelario had agreed
to play ben and mary but that also fell
through would any of these actors have
been able to save the movie bonnetta and
daddario don't exactly shine though
their characters are so thinly written
that it's little wonder so many actors
passed on the project beforehand they
certainly weren't helped by director
colin shifley who opts for action movie
cliches and excessive neon lighting over
any meaningful exploration of the
protagonist's characters
if you've already forgotten about the
2019 animated feature of the adams
family you're not alone despite boasting
an impressive voice cast including oscar
isaac and charlize theron as gomez and
morticia the kid-friendly reboot of this
classic property wasn't exactly a hit
with the critics though low production
costs meant it was still able to turn a
healthy profit a second film was
announced pretty much immediately and
the a-list voice cast all signed on to
reprise their roles unfortunately their
combined talents were not enough to save
this flat and equally forgettable
follow-up the addams family too is the
kind of film that could only be enjoyed
by an atoms because it's torture this
painfully unfunny sequel follows the
titular family on a camper van trip
organized by gomez who fears the adam's
clan isn't as tight-knit as it once was
detective pikachu scribes dan hernandez
and benji sammit were among the numerous
writers who contributed to the script
which is nevertheless paper-thin
extremely light on laughs and nowhere
near kooky enough for long-time adam's
family fans
empire magazine said of the film
ironically given the mantra for its main
characters is about embracing the weird
the adams family too does little that is
out there or different delivering a safe
stale 93 minutes
the halloween franchise got a fresh
start in 2018 when a brand new
installment blew up the box office and
scored rave reviews this new halloween
ignored all the films that had followed
1978's halloween and continued the story
of lori strode decades later the critics
loved it too the same cannot be said of
2021's halloween kills the shockingly
bland second entry in a planned sequel
trilogy halloween kills begins
immediately after the conclusion of the
previous film in which lori locked
escaped killer michael myers in the
basement of her house and set it ablaze
it soon becomes clear that responding
firefighters released him and he's
coming for lori once again but here's
what seemed to annoy people towards the
end of the movie myers is set upon by an
angry mob taking a beating that no
mortal man could survive yet he does
after being shot and stabbed multiple
times michael gets up and proceeds to
slaughter the now terrified townsfolk
this ending caused confusion and
disappointment in equal measure
seemingly confirming that michael myers
draws power from supernatural sources
previous halloween sequels have taken
this path and the original did actually
hint at it
i killed him
he can't kill the boogeyman
but nobody expected this movie to follow
suit making michael truly immortal was a
major cop-out that only served to set up
the final installment as such halloween
kills is a pointless stepping stone of a
movie doing nothing to advance the
overarching story and failing to deliver
any real scares either
sometimes something that works perfectly
on stage just doesn't make the same
impact on screen this is certainly the
case with dear evan hansen the story of
a high school loner who gets swept up in
a lie after a classmate dies by suicide
on the advice of his therapist evan
writes letters to himself some of which
mention his crush zoe connor zoe's
brother snatches one of his letters
before taking his own life which leads
everyone to assume the letter is conor's
last missive to evan instead of coming
clean evan manufactures a fake
friendship between him and conor putting
his parents minds at ease and allowing
him to get closer to zoe it's not easy
to get behind a character who would do
such a thing though ben platt made it
possible on broadway he reprises the
title role in the 2021 film adaptation
which keeps the tunes but lacks the
offbeat charm without an audience to
beat off of platt's performance falls
flat as far as the music is concerned
the songs don't have the same impact as
they did on stage as the chicago sun
times review pointed out upbeat tunes
and a heavy storyline about teen suicide
make a cringy combo
if you or anyone you know is having
suicidal thoughts please call the
national suicide prevention lifeline at
1-800-273-talk 8255